and this gets back to the conservative  inclination why I think conservatism is  more an inclination than it is in  ideology it's an inclination  fundamentally of humility of awe of  Wonder of knowing I'm not the greatest  guy that ever lived I don't celebrate  Pride I don't take pride in myself I I  try to be as aware as I can of my own  flaws and the great gift of humility one  life is a lot better when you go through  it and you you try to be humble but then  you also look back on history and you  say you know maybe maybe I shouldn't  throw stones at Thomas Jefferson he held  slaves I don't hold slaves so that's one  point for me I do a lot of things that  he didn't do that are pretty bad as well  just judging Society in the 19th century  there was widespread slavery in the  United States many people opposed it but  there it was  what are people going to say about us in  200 years